we love you man uh has any of this
gotten old yet no I mean other rewards
you're like oh another award show I I I
I I feel so lucky and grateful to be
here uh and uh this is all amazing it's
all so amazing and I'm having such a
good time yeah good
um Oscars this I'm really excited I know
you gotta yeah no I love it
um Oscars this week how are you
preparing yourself mentally for the
Oscars oh my gosh wow that's a good
question no I have not uh I'm trying to
take it one day at a time this is all so
special to me
um you know at one I never thought I
would ever be here uh and and all the
recognition all the attention that our
movie has gotten so far has just been
incredible uh and uh and I just want to
to be in the moment uh so I'm not that
far ahead yet what are you doing to like
check in with yourself on a daily basis
to like to stay in the moment to make
sure you're taking in as much as you can
you know every morning I wake up uh I I
take a minute to to make sure that this
is not all a dream uh and uh and
normally you know you know I look at
that like you know I I look at my wife
and she looks at me and and we are just
so grateful uh that everything has
happened so far uh and yeah it's uh it
feels incredible no I know we're gonna
see you next in Loki season two what can
you tell me about your role on that show
oh
it's good it's good the show is going to
be really good I can't wait for the fans
to see it if you're a Loki fan uh I
think I think we will make you uh very
happy potential you might pop up another
Marvel projects oh now if you ever see
Kevin feihi that would be an amazing
question to ask him I I would love to
because I love the MCU so much right on
man hope to yeah have fun today thank
you
thank you